the other day i dm'd a rapper that i
want to get on the show and he literally
replied in five minutes and was like
yeah i'll do it i was just like okay
this this cool this is good
who else are you keen to book
um
i'm keen to book drake
so
fingers crossed
[Music]
how would you describe yourself as a
teenager
um as a teenager so well in primary
school when i was younger i was quite
popular in primary school and then as
soon as i became a teenager and went to
secondary school i
wasn't popular at all
and
i was just involved in a lot of
extracurricular activities um so
i was the library assistant in the
library which meant i would like return
books in break and lunch which maybe is
why i didn't have that many friends now
i'm thinking about it i was also quite
awkward i think as a
teenager i had braces and glasses which
you know is never that great a look
um and i was also quite small like
smaller than i am now
so
it wasn't
it wasn't the best i always had
ambitions to be a performer but i can't
really pinpoint exactly what type of
performer i wanted to be
um i think maybe at the beginning it was
more of like a presenter because
growing up you know watching tv
presenters were like
huge and that was mainly how i thought i
could like
be on television if i was a presenter i
also feel like i wanted to be an actress
at some point
i was really obsessed with skins and i
wanted to be in skins which i probably
would not have been casting skins
considering i spent all my time in the
library
you went to university and you went to
study fashion how did you end up
studying
well yeah i went to university to
central saint martins to study fashion
journalism because another ambition of
mine was i always wanted to be editor of
vogue
and so
basically
um i used to yeah be it wanted to be
entrepreneur that was like how i would
introduce myself a lot like be like hi
emilia and i'm going to be editor of
vogue um and so my mum told me okay well
if you want to be editor of vogue you
have to go to central martins because
that's where you know all the big
fashion
designers and just people within the
industry have gone
so i set my mind on it from very young
age that i was going to go to central st
martin's did you like did you like
university did you enjoy it
i like the first two years because going
to martin's like everyone there is just
i mean hyper creative like the most
creative people you'll probably ever
meet and everyone was just
came in wearing the most insane outfits
like that they'd made or you just never
knew what you were gonna see and so much
of the courses was all about
collaboration so we'd be collaborating
with the fashion designers the architect
students like the graphic designers
everyone was in this big building in
king's cross so it really was fantastic
and yeah everyone there's talking about
ideas
rather than you know people and i love
that i loved that about it so i'm really
happy i went to like a creative
university but my tutors didn't really
get
me
nobody didn't really get me but they
didn't really get what i was doing so
when i was already doing chicken shop
date at the time when i was at
university i did the first episode when
i was in my first year at uni
and i think
like they just didn't really understand
it i mean fair enough it wasn't anything
to do with fashion um chicken shop date
but um
i also was always trying to do
make
content in my fashion studies so like
fashion content or like video interviews
or like funny
quirky things
and i don't really think
they understood it really so i often
came
into sort of clashes with my tutors and
i ended up really hating my third year
because my tutors really didn't like my
final project which was starting a
youtube channel
um
they said you know what they said they
said that they all wanted everyone to
make magazines
and they were like everyone in the class
had to make a magazine and i was like
guys i kind of think that like maybe
print is going down and like maybe we
should be doing video as instead and
they were like what are you talking
about absolutely not my i.t
teacher really liked me because i was a
scholar and um sent me an email saying
oh also he knew that i wanted to be
editor of vogue so he sent me an email
saying there's this
magazine that's run out of a youth club
in royal oak in north west london where
i'm from they're looking for new like
contributors
you should go and i was like this is
perfect like i've always wanted to write
for a magazine this is amazing so me and
my friend from my class cleo went on
wednesday evening after school and that
changed my life and i owe everything to
becoming part of that magazine it was
called the cut and
everyone there was
just into all different types
of music and different parts of culture
that i never knew and especially uk rap
and grime i was so
obviously inspired by pop world and
their really irreverent interviews that
they did where they
would just take
pop stars and put them in completely
different situations and it was so
fun and had so much energy and i was so
bored of seeing the same
interviews with musicians that were just
talking about their musical influences
and
just serious things i guess it just
seemed quite tame at the time
um so yeah i thought a date would be a
great way to do an interview and then
someone said oh you should go on a date
where you would never actually go on a
date so then i said chicken shot so
that's how it started and yeah it was a
column in that magazine for like three
years
so i would write up the interviews
and my friend would take photos
um and then when i was in my first year
of at uni after i'd done maybe like 10
interviews with the column
decided it would be
even better if it was filmed so just
made my youtube channel
so the first filmed episode of trick
shot eight was with um getz
and
yeah i still can't believe that he was
the first episode such a brilliant
person to get do you like pets
guests i like cats i like cats you know
the truth is a lot of people they laugh
when i say that i like cats
cats fascinate me they're very smart
very smart you know like sometimes
you'll just be you can be in a house
alone and the cat will be looking at
something
that you can't see
and that fascinates me yeah they also
jump really high
he was just like the perfect person to
be the first episode because he was just
so up for it and such a great bubbly
personality and also
so
just naturally funny that i just hit
gold really struck gold with that one oh
were you a bit nervous to go to the
camera
um was i nervous well the thing is
because i'd done a lot of the column
already and i was in character then i
developed my character through the
written column and i always felt like i
was performing even when there weren't
any cameras there so
i wasn't as nervous as i could have been
i was just nervous because i also
produced the content myself
um so i'm i've
with my friend marvin who also is from
the magazine we i found the shop book
the crew like not knowing what i'm doing
i've never produced a shoot before i was
20
and
like just scrambling around making sure
everything was going right so i think i
was just really concentrating on the
production of it making sure that even
that guetz showed up he was actually
early
if i was worried he wouldn't turn up and
then you know
the chicken shop owner it was in a
chicken cottage we didn't we didn't tell
him that we needed to actually shut the
shop so he assumed that he could still
serve his customers but the shop was so
small that when the camera crew was in
there
no one could get in so there was a line
of people outside the chicken shop just
like looking in and he was fuming that
he couldn't serve anyone what so where
did the character come from where's this
the kind of prickly awkward character
coming from the character's kind of just
an exaggeration of my own personality i
think growing up i was a lot more
awkward than i am now and deadpan and
people would always say that i was a bit
cold but i just think that they're just
reading me wrong i just think i have a
face where i look like i'm in a bad mood
but i'm not
like my face just i think i have a
downturn smile or something i don't know
what it is but i always look like i'm
unimpressed people often are like are
you okay
i'm like yes i'm fine
the first episode that blew up was
probably the chabadi g one because it
was put on lad bible actually
yeah it was put on lab bible and it blew
up um
so yeah thanks slab eyeball for that
what are your best chat up lines oh best
chat up lines uh you want to make some
beige little [ __ ] together and live
that you get nightmare hi buddy
it's been such a gradual
like
growth of the success of it that i don't
think it's ever been there's ever been a
moment where i'm like whoa i've made it
or like wow it's huge um because it's
been really steady but i i wouldn't have
had it any other way because i think
that it just makes it even better than
it's that it's grown over time and i've
built like a following
over time rather than just all of a
sudden because i think going viral and
getting like a mad amount of
people looking at your content and
subscribing and whatever when you're
starting out can actually
hinder you or can i think be quite
daunting because then there's so much
pressure and expectation when you are
still finding yourself and figuring your
your content out and what you're doing
and what what has been your favorite
episode
um my favorite episode
maybe the big nasty episode is my
favorite episode because i was trying to
get big nasty on the show for so long i
remember being at sonar festival in
spain and like having these phone
conversations with
someone loosely connected to him um this
was like
five years ago telling me that maybe
they could get
me a date with big nasty and i was like
leaving the festival to do these calls
with all my friends thinking oh my god
we're gonna get big nasty on it's gonna
be like the second episode it's gonna be
incredible and that never happened until
like two years later finally we got him
on and it was just a big deal i think
because also the fans really wanted him
on the show too and he was so great and
um
he he was just the perfect guest why are
you called big nasty if you're so fun
and cuddly and cute so his name's got a
meaning behind it
what does it stand for
natural artistic respected sexy talented
independent and educated
the bigger the show gets the bigger the
expectation to get a bigger artist is
and
big artists are always going to be hard
to get like no matter how successful a
platform you have even play people like
graham norton will find it hard to book
certain guests so i think that's always
just going to be difficult but but
definitely it's got to be easier like
the other day i dm'd a rapper that i
want to get on the show and he literally
replied in five minutes and was like
yeah i'll do it i was just like okay
this this cool this is good
who else are you keen to book
um
i'm keen to book drake
so
fingers crossed
in in your private life and your dating
life has anyone ever tried to take you
actually on a chicken shop
uh no
nobody has asked me out on a second date
no that's not happened
i know shocking
shocking but no it's actually quite
awkward sometimes well i've got less
awkward but i when i used to film when i
started filming i would i wouldn't talk
to the guests before
uh because i i don't know i was quite
method i don't know why um there's no
need really um so i wouldn't talk to
them before and then as soon as the
camera and the cameras stopped filming i
was like okay thank you bye
what's your favorite thing about making
sure i love
like getting excited about who i'm gonna
have on next i love writing the
questions um trying to ask
people something that they've never been
asked before the whole point of chicken
shop date is to get a different site
show a different side to that person's
personality make something entertaining
that is unique that they won't have seen
before and i think that's why people
like watching the show too
um and then i love being in the edit i
love editing i don't edit myself but i
sit in on the edit and i love putting
everything together and like the puzzle
pieces of what it's going to be like
because a lot of
the show the awkwardness and my
character is actually made in the edit
um
rather than
when we actually film live
what advice would you give to
aspiring content creators
who want to follow your footsteps um my
advice would be
just to be persistent i think is the
best advice i could give
just carry on emailing carry on like
nudging people um carry on making your
own content because
because people were gonna have to listen
and that's kind of what i've done also i
i believe that if you think that your
idea is is good then that's all you need
really because
you just need that belief to carry you
through to carry on making things
um so yeah that would be
my advice also i guess
um
find your niche i feel
like find something that
is a bit different i guess it's the
worst advice ever like think of an
original idea
um
do that but but really yeah i think that
everything i've done is kind of looking
at how i can spoof something that
already exists like
how i can
take something that you know i've seen
already but just add my own twist to it
which essentially what i've done with
with a dating show which is what chicken
shop day is and um a music interview
format just spinning it a bit you don't
have to
think of something from thin air so no
one ever does that everything is
referencing something else so i think
don't try and you know
go and
wind yourself up by trying to think of
something original because nothing is
original really
[Music]
you can never really be true friends
after something like that i just don't
think it can ever ever happen maybe if
you
fought and it was a draw
maybe you could still be friends but the
idea of being friends with someone that
has a beating you it's a hard thing for
your head to compute